viserys in a deal brokered by one of the
magisters of pentos the
illyrio mopatus um
he gives up his sister into marriage to
this horse lord
in return for promise of an army
the problem is that viserys doesn't
really understand the dothraki
and that also he's he's arrogant he has
a sense of entitlement
he doesn't understand the dothraki
culture you know and the dothraki are
not merchants they do not buy or sell
they trade
favors and they do it in their own time
so they look at it as
the the you know danny was given to
cadrogo as a gift
and in return he will give a gift of
this golden crown that he has promised
for ceres
drogo by the customs of his people is
obliged to return to vice dothrak
and to present his new bride to the dosh
khaleen
the crones who are at the heart of the
of the dothraki culture
and viserys tags along with him which is
a mistake on a whole number of levels
the horse people come to have great
contempt for saris
danny adjusts to their culture danny you
know rides
and starts wearing dothraki clothing and
learns their language
viserys doesn't do any of this he's the
king of westeros he
expects deference and all that and it
becomes more and more a problem
fantasy requires magic of some sort
otherwise without magic it's just
historical
fiction about history that never
happened
but i think you need to be very careful
about how you handle the magic and how
much of it you you put in
if you look at lord of the rings what
what strike
strikes you and certainly struck me is
that although the world
has is infused with this great sense of
magic there's very little on stage magic
you know gandalf is a wizard but you
don't see him
he doesn't obliterate entire armies with
a word
and lightning bolts from his fingers and
things like that
he's got a staff that glows a little
when
when orcs attack he takes out his sword
and fights side by side with
uh with the other people
so you you have a sense of magic but
it's
kept under very tight control and i
really took that to heart when i was
starting my
my own series um i think if you put too
much magic in your fantasy
it overwhelms the plot and it starts to
make the plot
nonsensical i mean if you do have a
sorceress or a wizard who can
speak a word and wipe out an army why
would you even assemble an army
this is one of the one of the scenes
where
you do get the sense that the there may
be something beyond
the things known to us there may be
forces at work here
that we don't entirely understand that
are
beyond nature supernatural and
uh that miri monster perhaps commands
some of them
um you know something is happening in
that
tent what exactly is this well we don't
really know
and i don't really want you to know i
want you to feel as
you know kind of frightened and
disturbed by it is
as uh as danny does
theon greyjoy is is uh as a result of
the great droid rebellion theon greyjoy
the the third son and only surviving son
of balon greyjoy the lord of pike
has been given to ned stark as
a ward if you defeat an enemy
and you make a peace the defeated lord
gives up some member of his family who
presumably he cares about
becomes a hostage
of the the one who's won the battle the
lord who's won the war
the the person who's defeated them and
they go and live in his
his household and because they are of
noble birth they're not
confined to a dungeon or anything like
that they're treated well
but they are a hostage there's sort of a
plight fiction
that they're the same as the foster
lings
but they're not they're treated the same
they they eat censor of noble birthday
they'll eat a table with the family
that's hosting them they'll be referred
to as
a ward or a foster ling but everybody
knows that they're hostage for their
father's good behavior
and that as much affection and
friendship
as there may seem to be
if there's any treason on part of the
father they they may pay with their
lives